[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Nia is
with us in Jacksonville Florida hi Nia
welcome to the Ramsey Show Oh Mr Ramsey
thank you so much for taking my call
hope all is well with you um so I I in
my 20s I listen to your read your books
and such purchased a home at 27 um
however I lost my job after 10 years and
I sold my condo in 2016 I live at home
I'm now 42 and I created a lot of debt
for myself but I want to purchase a
condo in 2025 so I just wanted your
advice and a strategy of on how what
what debt to pay down first um I have
$10,000 in total debt um three personal
loans three credit cards and I have
$45,000 student loan debt I'm still in
school seeking my masters and I'll be
done at the end of the year so I'm not
currently paying that right now I have $
36,42 in my 401k I I know I borrowed
from my 401k uh $20,000 to pay off my
debt which I ACR again um so right now
by- weekly I'm paying $1 17194 at 4.5%
interest on my
401k all right so what is your total
debt outside of uh you you don't have a
mortgage now so what's your total
Consumer Debt 10 10 plus 45 plus 20 on
the 401
right yes the 75
65 no the 401 is 3
36,42 no the loan balance the loan on
the 401 is 20 oh I'm sorry um $14,000
left to pay oh 14 on that okay yeah and
it's 171 by weekly per my paycheck and a
4.5 so you got about $70,000 in debt and
you make
what um right now it just got raised so
6,400 I you know wasn't making much but
now I am making more and I recently paid
off my car in 2021 unless your income
changes you're not going to buy a house
in
25 right what's your Masters in what
what a condo I wanted a condo I'm I work
in
education um I work in education so it's
obviously you don't cre that much in
education so will this Masters increase
your income condo um not much then why
are you doing but it's required well
it's required um right now I'm not
paying for it the school pays for it and
because I work in education it's
required to have a higher degree but the
school pays 90% of that Nia you need to
pay off
$70,000 say save up a down save up an
emergency fund then save up a down
payment well right now I have uh $3500 I
just don't don't know if I should but I
have three personal loans um 35 35 25
yeah and you have 45,000 in student loan
debt and you have 20, ,000 on a 401K you
have $770,000 in
debt okay I didn't look at it like that
but yes so here's the hard truth you're
not going to be ready to buy a house a
year from now it may be two or three
years from now wow we have to get rid of
the debt you don't have 70,000 coming
in in the next 12 months you have 60,000
coming in and you have 70,000 in
debt right yeah um what I was thinking
maybe I should pay off my save up year
pay off you know my uh 401K the $144,000
just flat out paid off or if I should
pay the high interest rate that I have
on the personal loan I think we're
beyond the math of interest rates I
would just list all of your debts out
from smallest to largest make minimum
payments on all the debts except for the
smallest one and we're going to attack
that one with a Vengeance as much extra
on the principle as you can throw at it
and that might mean you're doing side
jobs after your master's program after
your full-time job when you complete
your Masters when in the end of this
year so 12 more months uh-huh okay all
right do you have any time to do
tutoring during while you're working on
your
Masters not really I mean the job is is
pretty demanding you know sometimes I do
have to work weekends now you said
you're living at home with your
parents yes okay so you have almost no
expenses what are you having to pay for
right now the loans that I have on the
credit cards um I do give them
contribute $600 but it's the loans that
I have the personal loans you know
situations happen and obviously I did
that but okay honey you're going to have
to draw a line in the S and quit
borrowing money I don't hear anymore
about your situations you've situation
yourself into your parents basement you
got to qu situation so um cut up the
credit cards get yourself on a beans and
rice rice and beans budget anything you
can do to increase your income like
tutoring let's go do it and uh let's
start attacking these debts just exactly
like George said smallest to largest and
it's going to take you a little while to
clear $70,000 in debt when you get that
clear you can talk talk about buying a
house you may go rent something in the
meantime but I wouldn't buy until you
get this mess cleaned up create your
free every dollar budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life